now it's your turn to add the
functionality to create conferences to
your application first though you need
to copy over some files into your
project in the lesson 4 folder you'll
find Conference Java and you're going to
need to copy it into the domain package
in your project and you can just drag
and drop it from wherever you downloaded
it right into the domain package in
Eclipse also go ahead and copy over the
conference form Java file and put it in
the forum package conference dot Java
and Conference form dot Java files
contain completed code but don't worry
we haven't done everything for you
you're going to need to copy the
skeleton version of create conferences
into the conference API class and it's
going to be your job to finish
implementing the create conference
function after you drag and drop your
files into eclipse
you're going to need to refresh your
project go ahead and right-click on the
project name and then you choose refresh
and then your project will refresh and
it'll show the files that you just
copied over if you forget to refresh it
you might not see the files and then you
might be in a panic where they are so
remember to refresh when you've copied
the files and the function into your
project go ahead and have a look at the
conference Java file and the conference
forum Java so now here's a quick
question for you
does conference form have properties
that map to these properties in
conference does conference form have a
property that maps to the name property
in conference does it have a property
that maps to the topics property in
conference and so on so just check all
that apply